complex problems always yield better
results when tackled by a team of people
with different specializations and with
AI agents it works exactly the same way
individual expertise combined creates
exponentially better Solutions because
just like with humans AI agents work
better the more narrow their role and
goals are it is all about Focus I know
you have seen it before where you're
building your AI agent and it works
really well at first but then as you
continue to add more instructions and
tools it starts to hallucinate even with
the things that it was doing well with
at first and it's so frustrating cuz
llms they just get overwhelmed so
quickly and fragmenting your AI agent
into different sub agents to handle
different components is one of the best
ways to solve for this and take your AI
agents to that next level and that is
exactly what I'm going to show you how
to do right now because here's the thing
creating an army of specialized agents
takes a lot of consideration how do you
split up the problem what tools do your
agents need how do you combine the work
done by all the agents at the end and
most importantly one llm by itself
already takes a while to get a response
and so if you have to have many
specialized agents running together how
do you make it so that your system
doesn't take ages to run but it's all
right take a deep breath cuz I'm going
to cover this all with you in this video
so that by the end these kind of agentic
systems are as clear as day to you both
the how and equally important the why
we'll build a parallel agent
architecture using my two favorite
Frameworks pantic Ai and Lang graph so
we have a group of specialized agents
that are running simultaneously all
working to accomplish the same goal this
is hands down one of the most important
agent architectures and throughout this
video I have a lot of tips and trick
sprinkled in for both pantic Ai and Lane
graph a lot that I'm sharing with you
here so let's go ahead and dive right
into it so let's start with the basics
what is the parallel agent architecture
at its core and I think that this
article from anthrop IC on building
effective agents explains it the best at
a high level and it was published a
while ago but I still refer to this
constantly because it's just a great
resource covering all the different
agent architectures that you and I
should be paying attention to and they
even mentioned Lang graph in this
article which is super neat and they do
give a warning about Frameworks it's a
level of abstraction that can sometimes
be dangerous so you have to understand
how these Frameworks work under the hood
but that's why I'm showing you how to do
things with Lang graph and pantic AI in
this video and then scrolling down they
have these diagrams for all these
different architectures the one that
we're going to be focusing on is this
one right here parallelization and so we
have the input com in from a user and
then that's fed into these different
green boxes each of these represent an
AI agent with its own instructions and
tools to tackle a certain part of the
problem and then you have an aggregator
at the end in this case this is not a
large language model that's what the
purple box signifies that just takes the
output from each of the agents in
parallel and prod produces some sort of
nicely formatted output combining all
the results for the end user like you or
I and then in my case I even want to
take this a little bit further and so we
have a similar flow here but instead of
there just being a non llm that
Aggregates the results we use yet
another AI agent as a synthesizer to
take the output from each of our
parallel agents and figure out a way to
summarize it format it whatever for that
final output for the user I'm just
calling it a parallel agent architecture
in our case instead of a work quo for
orchestrator workers just because this
is just a better name parallel agents
and so the architexture that we have for
our agent today is this so what you're
looking at here is a visual
representation of the L graph workflow
for the agent that we are building we're
making a travel planner assistant agent
today it's a very good example of an AI
agent that could operate just as a
single agent but there's a lot that goes
into planning a trip and so we have
these specialized sub agents to handle
different components like the flight
hotel and recommending activities and so
at the start of this conversation we
gather information from the user where
are they flying to where are they flying
from how many days is their trip going
to be for and so we have this initial
Loop making sure we get all the
information and then once we have all of
that then we move on to the parallel
part of our workflow having these
different agents plan everything for the
trip in parallel and then the results
for all of these agents they're
recommended commendations are fed into
this final synthesizer agent that just
summarizes all of it in a neat package
to present to you for its final
recommendation for everything and we
even have a streamlet user interface
built out for this travel planner
assistant you can give your preferences
for things like your Airlines and the
amenities that you want in your hotel a
budget level and then you can save these
preferences and then I can ask it to
plan a trip for me so for example I can
say I want to plan a trip frying from
Minneapolis to Paris uh in June and then
my Max budget for a hotel is $200 per
night and look at this I don't know if
you caught that there but each of these
lines were printed out at exactly the
same time and that is the beginning of
the execution of each of those sub
agents in this parallel workflow and it
happens so fast like it's already
printing out the final results from the
synthesizer streaming it out to my
interface here but it was doing all of
that in parallel it got the flight
recommendations Hotel recommendations
and activity recommendations at exactly
the same time using different agents
that were given different tools and
instructions for that specific task and
then giving me the final output at the
end it is super neat so with our travel
planner assistant we're not going to be
using real flight hotel or weather data
it's all mocked just because we want a
simple example and focusing on the
architecture itself versus the tooling
but as usual I go above and beyond
providing a lot of value so if you want
to see the parallel agent architecture
in in a full-fledged use case check out
archon this is an AI agent that builds
other AI agents completely free and open
source this project that I'm pouring
myself into right now and I recently
implemented the parallel agent
architecture and so I'll have a link to
this GitHub repo in the description but
take a look at this you can ask archon
to autonomously refine the AI agent that
it produces the code for and then it'll
kick off this parallel workflow with
these agents to refine The Prompt tools
and agent and archon is an mCP server so
you can literally hook it into your AI
IDE like I'm doing with wind surf here
and so first I ask it to build an agent
using archon that searches the web with
brave it produces this pantic AI agent
for me so I've got all the code for it
here but then I can ask it to refine the
agent and so after that initial creation
you can see that I just ask it to refine
it and then this kicks off that parallel
workflow to make all those revisions and
then wind surf comes back and adds in
all these code changes so we have
parallel agents we've got wind surf
working with an mCP sub agent there's so
much cool stuff going on here so dive in
this if you wanted to go into something
insane but to start simple and really
make sure we understand this
architecture let's get into the code for
the travel planner assistant here is the
GitHub repository for the travel
planning assistant all the code that
we're going to create together right now
I'll have a link in the description to
this repo if you go there on the
homepage you have this read me where I
cover the architecture and also how you
can can get up and running yourself if
you want to follow along or take what
I've built here and tweak it for your
own use cases so I cover setting up your
environment um your variables running
the streamlet interface that I showed
earlier all that good stuff and so the
plan right now is I'm going to walk you
through building the pantic AI agents
that make up all the individual
components for our workflow so all of
the agents that you see in the agents
folder those correspond to the different
nodes that we have in our ra we have the
infog Gathering agent the specialized
agents who are planning the trip and
then that final synthesizer all those
are individual Python scripts that you
can see right here and so I'll walk you
through creating one of the agents from
scratch we'll create the flight agent
from scratch and then I'll briefly show
you each of the other agents that are
going to be created in a very similar
way with pantic AI and then with that we
can dive into building our Lang graph
graph combining all these agents
together to create the full process and
so with that let's get into building our
first agent so to make this as simple as
possible for you you can think of
building pantic AI agents as building
three distinct parts so let me show you
the documentation with a really nice
example to demonstrate this so this is
the weather agent just very simple
implementation that I cover a lot it
just shows these different components
very well when you're building an agent
the first component is defining the
dependencies these are things like the
API keys and database connections that
your agent tools need for the agent to
do things on your behalf then the second
component is the definition of the agent
itself and so this is where you specify
things like the large language model you
want to use the system prompt the exact
dependencies and a lot of other
different parameters that pantic AI
offers for things like defining
automatic retries for your agent as well
and then the last component which
usually takes most of your code for an
agent is defining the tools itself and
so you have all the functionality
wrapped up in a function that the agent
can call upon when it wants to do
something specific and in this dock
string this larger comment that you have
at the top of the function this is where
you specify to the agent when and how to
use each of these tools so you give it
the purpose and the arguments so I can
reason about when it would invoke this
tool specifically and what arguments
that you would pass in for something
like the location in this example and
you just Define all the individual tools
in the same way so that's a good
overview of how we build an agent with
pantic AI we're going to follow a very
similar structure here building our
flight agent so first we'll start by
importing all of the libraries that we
need and defining some of our
configuration like getting the exact
large language model that we want which
in this utils.py I just have this simple
function to get that based on our
environment variables that we set next
up I want to Define my dependencies for
the flight agent in this case we're
keeping it very simple again this is
just more of a demonstration focusing on
the architecture versus making really
robust agents and so in this case our
dependencies we just have the preferred
Airlines for the user so they're going
to set that in the streamlet UI like we
saw in the demo earlier and then that's
given as a piece of information to our
flight agent then we can Define our
system prompt just giving the
instructions to the flight agent for its
role and goals and how to use the tools
that we give it as well and then that
brings us to our second component for
building agents which is the definition
for the agent itself so we give it just
like we saw in the documentation the
model system prompt dependencies and
giving it some automatic retries and
then with that out of the way we can get
on to the very last part I mean it's
it's pretty simple overall because now
we're just defining the tools for the
agent and so we use this python
decorator above the function definition
itself to tell pantic AI that this is a
tool for our flight agent that we just
defined above and then the parameters
here the large language model decides
what we're going to use for the origin
destination and date for searching
flights and then this run context this
is how pantic AI injects the
dependencies like the preferred flights
into this function and so at the very
beginning just like we saw in the docs
we're going to have a comment here this
doc string that tells the agent when and
how to use this function and then we can
get straight into the implement ation
cuz really tools for agents are just
functions that you wrap up and send as a
part of the prompt to the llm and so in
this case we're using mock data so we
have this dictionary that simulates
something you might get back if you used
a real flight API and so we return a few
flight options and then if there are any
preferred airlines that the user
specified we're going to change the
order of the flights based on their
preferences and then just add a note
that this flight was preferred or maybe
multiple flights were prefer referred
and so the result of all of this is then
just going to be returned for this
function and so whatever is returned
here this Json string is going back to
the llm so the agent the flight agent
invokes this tool to search for flights
and then that list of sorted flights
based on preferences is given back so I
can then reason about that and give the
final answer to the user for what flight
it recommends and even though we're
building this agent to be a part of a
larger architecture we can use this
flight agent in olation and have a
conversation with just it and so in this
extras folder I created this flight C.P
script and so this is a way for us to in
the terminal have a conversation with
the flight agent and there's a bit more
of a complex implementation that I have
here for streaming the output from the
pantic AI agent I won't go in the weeds
for this but I spent a good amount of
time figuring this out so take this and
use it for yourself it'll definitely
save you a headache if you want to
stream the output from your pantic AI
agents so that not only do you get the
response from the agent but you get the
tokens out in real time as it is
producing the response and so back over
in the terminal I can run this command
to run the flight CLI and then I can say
something basic like Hello this won't
cause it to search for flights but then
I can say something like I want to go
from Minneapolis to Tokyo on June 1st
and based on what I sent here it's going
to pick out the origin destination and
date use that tool to search for flights
and then stream out its recommendations
to me obviously it's going to give me
the same recommendations no matter what
I say because it's not really searching
for flights but yeah this is working
beautifully and then for the rest of our
agents they're built in the same way the
sponsor of today's video is lutra a
userfriendly solution for creating
automated workflows with natural
language ever wish your AI assistant
could actually do things and not just
chat I mean sure most platforms have web
search and canvas at this point but that
is not enough lutra is a full-fledged AI
agent that connects seamlessly with your
favorite services like slack and Gmail
and then it can do things within those
Services based on your conversation so
it's very similar to a custom agent that
you or I would make but the really cool
part is that it creates code to take
these actions on your behalf and then
you can save that code as an automated
workflow to reuse later or set up as a
scheduled task called A playbook they're
also launching this brand new plugin
platform which is going to allow lutra
to connect to literally any API you just
give it the documentation and then it'll
be able to write code to connect to that
service just like the native
Integrations it is super neat and so
what does lutra actually look like well
I'll show you a quick demo of it right
now so to show you the power of lutra
I'm obviously going to give it a request
that something like Claude or GPT would
not be able to do so I'm going to ask it
to get a list of poll requests from
archon my AI agent Builder from GitHub
and then add them to a Google sheet and
it's going to start right off the bat by
reasoning to itself and you can watch
this reasoning which is really cool and
then it'll ask me a couple of follow-up
questions so I'll go ahead and answer
those and then what it's going to do is
ask me to connect the necessary accounts
for it to have that authorization for
both Google Drive and GitHub and in this
case I already connected GitHub so I'm
showing you that I don't have to
reconnect it but it is going to ask me
to connect my Google Drive so first
it'll create that code for this custom
integration and then it'll ask me to
connect my Google API all right so I'm
all connected and now it just continues
right away so I don't even have to go
somewhere else to configure my
credentials I just do it right here in
the chat when it's required for the
first time and now it's doing everything
that I asked it to do and boom look at
that it even opens up the Google sheet
within the lutra UI on the right hand
side it looks absolutely perfect pulled
all my active PRS tells me my sheet ID
asks me what I want to do next we can
see all the actions that it did within
GitHub and Google sheet this is just
incredible to me pretty slick right luch
is like having an AI agent that can
reason think and build Integrations for
you so you're not just chatting with it
it's doing stuff for you and building
automations at the exact same time and
it's totally free to get started so you
can head on over to lutra doai I'll have
a link in the description definitely
worth checking them out so that is the
flight agent now we can dive really
quickly into the other specialized
agents I'm going to go fast because this
setup is very similar take a look at
this this is our hotel agent so we've
got our dependencies again and this time
it is going to be the amenities that
we're looking for and our budget level
then we have a system prompt structured
in a very similar way we Define our
agent and then we have a tool to look up
hotels so that it can make a
recommendation so we have again this
mock dictionary this is what a real
hotel API would give something like this
and then we filter and sort based on the
max price preferred amenities and the
budget level and then return the final
list of TS so the agent can reason about
that to make its
recommendation and then for the activity
agent we don't even have dependencies in
this case so it is even simpler we just
have our agent definition with the
system prompt and then because the
weather oftentimes dictates what
activities you can do on a trip we give
it a tool to look up the weather so
based on the date and a city we have
this mock data so for a few cities it
can look at the temperature and then use
that to reason about if it's going to
recommend more indoor activities or more
outdoor activities whatever it might
dictate based on the weather so those
are all of our specialized agents we've
covered everything for these three right
here now we just have two left we have
our final synthesizer agent and then our
info Gathering agent and so starting
with the simpler one we have our final
planner and take a look at this there's
not even a tool for this agent because
it's main job its only job is to take
the recommended hotels flights and
activities and combine it together in a
nice summary this is also a good
opportunity to have an agent that could
validate the different outputs from the
other agents you can use a synthesizer
as a validator as well and add different
tools to do that but in our case to keep
it very simple it is just an agent with
a system prompt nice and easy and then
the last agent that we have is our info
Gathering agent and what makes this
agent Special is that we are using
structured outputs to guarantee that
every single response from this agent
has these key pieces of information and
the reason I'm doing this besides it
just being a good opportunity for me to
show you pantic AI structured outputs is
because we want to guarantee that we
have the necessary information for our
specialized sub agents to invoke the
tools that they need to invoke to search
for flights hotels and weather data and
so we get the destination origin Max
hotel price the dates that they're
leaving and returning everything that
our sub agents need and then we have the
resp response this is what we give back
to the user as they're conversating with
this infog Gathering agent and then
finally we have this all important
Boolean value that determines if the
user has given all of the necessary
values and this is what we key off of to
determine in our graph if we can
continue to the rest of this flow
invoking our parallel agents and so at
the beginning the user might say
something like I want to take a trip to
Germany and then the G infog Gathering
agent will be okay cool but I don't have
enough information to call upon the rest
of these agents here I need to know
where you flying from what dates are
your trip going to be and so the user
will give all that information and then
we can continue to the rest of the
process but if they don't give what's
required we continue in this Loop until
they do that's the important job of this
infog Gathering agent is to gatekeep the
rest of the process to make sure that
the agents don't hallucinate Because by
the time it gets to them they will have
all of the necessary information and so
the rest of the agent is defined in a
very similar way where we just have a
system prompt and then the definition
for the agent itself and then the way
that we can enforce that it produces a
Json output that matches this structure
is we just add this single line to our
pantic AI agent the result type is and
then we pass in our class that we
defined right here for travel details
and that is it we have now defined all
of our agents in this graph and so now
we can take each of them and piece them
together in in our Lang graph
implementation and just like with pantic
AI you can think of Lang graph
implementations as being three distinct
parts and I just love breaking down
complex things like this if you can
compartmentalize the different parts of
what goes into a process it just makes
it a lot easier to understand and so for
Lang graph our first part is the state
for the graph these are the key pieces
of information that you want to keep
track of throughout the execution that
your agents will use you'll give back to
the user things like the conversation
history and the results from the
different agent executions then the
second part is defining all of the nodes
for the graph and So within each node
you have all the logic to do something
like invoke an AI agent or in Lane graph
each node doesn't even have to call upon
an llm you can just have deterministic
code if you want and sometimes that's
even better than using large language
models that can be all over the place
sometimes so that's the second thing and
then the very last component the third
component to Lang graph is setting up
the graph itself so you take the State
you take your nodes you define all of
them within a graph instance and then
you connect them all together with edges
and that's it that's all that goes into
building a graph but what I'm going to
do with you right here to walk you
through it step by step is I am going to
delete everything take a look at this
all right boom it is gone we have a
blank slate so I'm going to walk you
through this step by step to really make
sure you understand how we are
connecting all these agents together and
managing the state for everything in L
graph so the first thing we're going to
do is support all of our libraries that
we need and the different agents that
we're going to be running through our
nodes then we can knock out right away
the first part of our graph which is the
state and so this is everything that we
have to keep track of throughout the
execution of our workflow and so we have
the latest user message we are building
up conversation history specifically for
the infog Gathering agent the rest of
the agents don't really need
conversation history then we have the
travel details that's that structured
output from our info Gathering agent
we'll store that because we need to use
it for the rest of our agents and then
we have user preferences the result from
each of the parallel agents and then
finally what is aggregated together into
that final plan from our synthesizer
agent is stored here so that's the state
now we can get on to building the graph
itself so I'll show you setting up the
structure for the graph and then we'll
get into building each individual node
and so the first thing is you want to
create an instance of the graph and then
you pass in the travel state so now we
know what the state is going to look
like for this graph and then we can
Define all of our nodes and again
there'll be a separate python function
for each of these nodes right now I'm
just adding them into the graph one at a
time all the nodes that you see here
like Gathering info getting the next
user message getting flight
recommendations these names correspond
exactly with the nodes that we see in
this graph because the lane graph Studio
that we're looking at right here it
looks at this python script it builds
the graph and then it displays exactly
how we set it up with our nodes and then
also the edges which we're defining here
so we start with the infog Gathering
agent and then we have this conditional
Edge and so this is that decision right
here do we get the next user message to
continue the conversation to gather the
info or do we pass on to our specialized
parallel agents to finish the workflow
recommend the travel details so we make
that decision based on this function
that we'll Define later as well and then
we add an edge from getting next user
message to Gathering info because once
we get more details from the user we
want to pass back to the info Gathering
agent to determine if it has everything
it needs now and then finally we add
edges from all the specialized agents
going all three into the same create
final plan node because that's how we
can take the outputs from all three and
bring them together into the synthesizer
all at the same time and then finally
our synthesizer agent just goes to the
end of of the graph now we can move on
to building out the nodes for our graph
and so starting with our first one the
Gathering info agent and so we take two
pieces of information for this function
we have our state so it can access
things like the message history and user
input and then we also give it a writer
I'm not going to go into the Weeds on
this but this is a custom object that
you can pass in in Lan graph which
allows us to stream the output from our
pantic AI agents so we watch The Tokens
come out in real time and so first we'll
will get the user input from the state
and then we'll build up the message
history over time because we want our
info Gathering agent to be
conversational because different parts
of the trip are going to be given by the
user throughout a couple of messages
potentially and the reason we're using a
model messages type adapter here this is
a special object that we have from
pantic AI is because when we get our
messages from a pantic AI agent we need
to convert it into a format that we can
store in a database and to make it very
compatible with databases like postgress
we choose Json B binary Json that's the
format that we store our conversation
history in the database and in the state
here but then when we retrieve that
conversation history to use a again in a
pantic agent we have to convert it back
into the format for pantic AI so that
it's an object in Python not just Json
being that's what we're doing here so
one of the more complicated parts of
pantic AI I hope that makes sense though
and so now with the conversation history
we can invoke our agent using run Stream
So that we get the tokens outputed in
real time and we just have to pass in
the user input and then the conversation
history and also if you want to run
synchronously like you don't want to
stream the output you just want to get
it all at once I have this comment right
here which you could use instead it
simplifies things a lot but I think a
lot of you appreciate having streamed
output it just makes the agent feel
snappier and more responsive so I wanted
to show you how to do that and so the
way that we do that it's kind of unique
here because remember this infog
Gathering agent it streams out a
structured response we have that Json
object I can even go back to the agent
and show you that definition again we
have this Json object that we're
outputting and so it's not as simple as
just streaming out a string because it's
a dictionary that has these different
values and so there's a very specific
way to do this in pantic AI that I I
don't want to dive into a ton but if you
go to their documentation they do show
you how to do this so I just poked
around for a couple of hours with this
documentation figuring out how to best
do it using this example right here
streaming structured responses and so
you can see that when you run an agent
in stream mode and it outputs a
structured response the output that you
get over time as it streams out the
tokens is going to look something like
this where it slowly builds up the
values in the dictionary and even within
a single key it can build up that string
over time and that's what we're going to
do with our response and so over time
we're building up the travel details.
response because this piece of
information is what we want to give to
the user as the output and then the rest
of the items we're just keeping track of
these behind the scenes because that'll
get past into our other agents later
this is the most complicated part of the
entire graph so I hope that makes sense
to you and then we're just validating
the Json at each iteration and we are
using this debounce bu so that we're not
every single split second validating the
Json structure we're just doing it every
you know .01 seconds here validating
that the Json is good Json and then
finally at the very end if we have a
valid travel details. response then
we're going to write that out to the
user and we're going to save this to our
graph state so we get the results from
invoking our agent and we append that
conversation history so we're adding on
to the conversation history and then
also setting the travel details to that
structured output that we just got and
so now travel details is going to be an
object that contains all of these pieces
of information that we can reference
later from our other specialized agents
and then luckily the rest of our nodes
are definitely simpler so starting with
our flight recommendations node and so
same arguments that we're passing in
we're going to get the travel details
and preferred Airlines from our state so
this is set by the user in the front end
and then this is what was just set by
our info Gathering agent and then we
also write out to the screen that we are
getting flight recommendations so
remember we saw in the demo earlier that
it wrote out to the screen getting
flight recommendations getting Hotel
recommendations getting activity
recommendations all at the exact same
time so I'm just putting this in here so
that we can see that this is truly
simultaneous execution CU sometimes
people will say it's parallel when
really it's just running one after the
other sequentially just combining the
output put at the end but this is truly
parallel and that's really important
because otherwise this workflow would
take a long time if it wasn't
simultaneous and so then we're going to
set up our dependencies for the flight
just with the preferred airlines that we
get from the state and we can create our
prompt and invoke our flight agent so
we're injecting the key pieces of
information from the travel details into
this prompt here so that our flight
agent has the information that it needs
to invoke that tool and then we just
call it and we do it synchron ly this
time so I'm not doing any fancy
streaming stuff here because there's
nothing that we want to write to the
screen yet we want to wait until we have
everything synthesized together and then
stream that out to the user and then in
the meantime we'll just say that we're
loading that we're getting the flight
recommendations so pretty simple and
then the only thing that we want to
update in the state for the graph is the
flight results so we just take the
results from invoking the agent get the
data and then that's just a string that
we store in Flight results and then for
our other parallel agents it's going to
look very similar so getting Hotel
recommendations again we just get the
necessary pieces of State build up the
hotel dependencies and then we create
that prompt again passing in the key
information from the travel details and
then running that agent and then we just
set the hotel results to that string the
results. data and then finally for the
activity recommendations it is exactly
the same so I'm just glossing over this
really quick there's nothing new to go
over in this node we just have to to get
it set up and then we have our
synthesizer agent and so this time what
we're going to do is take the state that
we have for each of our parallel agents
because at this point because you set it
up this way in the graph we have all of
that defined it's guaranteed to be
defined for each of those specialized
agents so we get those different pieces
of information and then we build up this
prompt where we are asking it to
summarize all of these recommendations
and then we give it the flight hotel and
activity recommendations and we ask it
to create a comprehensive travel plan
based on these recommendations and then
we just run a stream so we call the Run
stream again and then we're going to
stream a little bit differently it's
simpler this time because it's not a
structured output it's just a regular
string and so we can call the stream
text function instead and it's going to
give us a bunch of different chunks
basically portions of the response that
we can use that custom writer object
that we have here to stream the response
out to the front end like we saw earlier
in streamlet when I gave you that demo
and then finally we can get the response
just like we did with our other agents
and then set the final plan to that
value and that is it we have defined
everything for our agent nodes and so
now we can just Define a couple of the
other pieces that we need like for
example when we make that decision do we
have all the information we need to
continue or do we have to keep asking
the user for more travel details we're
doing this with this routing function
here so first we get the travel details
cuz remember going back to the graph
here this message get next user message
it goes back to gather info and then we
make the decision which one do we route
to and so when we're making that
decision we have the travel details
defined because that happens after the
Gathering info agent so we get the
details and then we just see is all
details given that Boolean value that it
defines right here is this true true or
false and if it's true if they have
given all of the necessary details then
we can move on but if it's false like we
see right here then we have to move on
to that node to get the next user
message and then we'll display in that
response variable to the user like hey I
need the destination or I need the dates
you're going on your trip then we get
that from the user then it comes back
and we would make this decision a second
time after we get a response and so if
we are good to continue if all details
given is true then we can just return a
list of the nodes that we want to move
on to and so when we return a list in a
router function like this in L graph
that means that we're going to execute
all of these nodes in parallel so it is
that easy to get simultaneous execution
of nodes and laning graph just like this
and within our Edge the dictionary or
the array I should say right here this
just defines all the different nodes
that we could route to and so just like
we have a list here we have a subset
that we return these are the ones that
we want to execute which is basically
everything except the get next user
message node and then finally for the
node itself to get the next user message
we're using this concept in Lan graph
called an interrupt this is how you add
human in the loop to L graph which is a
very powerful way to no matter where
you're at in the execution of a l graph
workflow you can stop and wait for the
user to input something so in this case
we're waiting for them to provide a
value and I'll show you later how this
is set up in the streamlet UI we're
waiting for the user to provide a value
which we then set as the user input so
we stop the graph here we're not running
it anymore we wait for them to input a
message and then we set user input to
whatever their message is and because we
have the edge that takes get user
message back to gather info that's how
we then repeat the process of calling
our info Gathering agent and so with
that out of the way we now have
everything we need for our nodes and so
the last thing that I want to add here
is memory for our agent so that it can
remember the state of the graph when we
have that human in the loop interrupt
we're just using a simple memory saver
so it's going to save it on the RAM on
my machine you can set up a SQL light or
a postgress memory saver if you want to
use superbase or something to store all
this state so you can make it very
persistent in production ready as well
if you want I'm just keeping it simple
and then finally we'll just call our
build travel agent graph so that we have
this travel agent graph instance that we
can now reference somewhere else to call
into this graph and that's what we do in
our streamlet UI so for the streamlet
interface let me show you really quickly
how we interact with our agent and so
first we import the travel agent graph
that we just defined right here so we
have an instance of the graph that we
can then use within our UI anywhere and
so in our function specifically to
interact with the agent invoke agent
graph we take in the user input as a par
parameter and then we first Define our
configuration including a thread ID this
is how we can have a unique identifier
for this specific execution of our Lan
graph graph and then if it is the first
message from the user as in the current
chat history just has a length of one
that means we're invoking the graph for
the first time so we build up our
initial state where we have the first
user message and then we have all the
preferences that they set in the UI and
then with all of that we just use the
aam function call for our travel agent
graph giving the initial State the
config that has the thread ID and then
stream mode equals custom is how we have
that writer object passed into our nodes
so that our pantic AI agents can stream
the output in real time to our front end
because we just use this async 4 so that
as we're getting those chunks we're able
to yield those and display them in real
time and then if we have more than just
a single message in the chat history
that means that the convers ation has
already began with our info Gathering
agent and we want to continue it and so
in our graph that's where we have this
interrupt here where we are waiting for
that next value from the user and so to
send in that value we call the agent in
a very similar way as when it's the
first message except instead of passing
in our initial State we're using this
command directive in Lang graph where we
say resume is equal to user input so
whatever you set resume to here that is
what that value gets defined as for that
human in the loop interrupt and so value
is now whatever user message and that's
what's set for the user input State and
so we're just passing in user input for
the resume here and then the rest of it
the same we just give the config and
then the stream mode of custom yield
each message so we're streaming out that
response it's it that's it and I'm not
going to dive into the exact setup for
the streamly interface and everything
like that because that's not the focus
of this video but with that we can now
just I'll show you the command here you
can just run streamlit run and then the
name of the UI I forgot to save which is
why I got that error but yeah you just
run this command and then that'll spin
up the UI in the browser for you so we
can go ahead and chat with our agent and
so I can say my name is Cole my
preferences are I like Ocean Air for my
Airline I really want to have a
restaurant and free breakfast because
I'm just a foodie I guess um and then a
budget level of mid-range I'll sa my
preferences and then just like with our
initial demo let's just have a fun
conversation with it so I'll say I'm
want to go to Spain all right and so
obviously this isn't enough information
at first and so now the agent the info
Gathering agent is going to ask for more
details and it's not the nicest response
it's just very blunt like boom give me
more you could obviously change that in
the system prompt if you want I just
kept it very basic but I'll say I'm
flying from Minneapolis just keep that
same thing going um going June 1st
through the 6th um and I don't want to
spend more than let's just say $250 per
night for a hotel all right so we give
it all the information that it needs and
now yep there we go we have everything
that we need and look at that it invokes
all three of our specialized agents at
the exact same time so we're just
waiting for all three of them to finish
and then it's going to get fed into our
synthesizer agent that streams the
output look at this your comprehensive
travel plans for Spain and and Bam this
is really fast this is using GPT 40 mini
under the hood for the llm for all of
these agents by the way and yeah this is
just awesome again just using all mock
data so it's not like the most amazing
thing but yeah here we go we got our
restaurant this one doesn't have free
Wi-Fi or or free breakfast rather so it
didn't accommodate all of our
preferences but it did for the flight it
said Ocean Air so it did its best based
on the mock data that we gave it yeah
this is working so well and you can take
this kind of architecture and and all
the things that I taught you here with
pantic AI and Lang graph and use this
for your own use case and get really
complex with it you can turn your
synthesizer agent into a validator as
well you can give a ton of powerful
tools to your different specialized
agents to really take advantage of the
fact that you can split up the different
tasks in that way there's so many ways
that you can take this further a lot of
things I want to do with that with my
content going forward as well so there
you have it you now have what it takes
to build specialized AI agents that run
in parallel
and that just unlocks that next level of
building agentic systems that are far
more powerful than what you could do
with just a single AI agent so this
architecture it's not just efficient it
is transformative for the way that
allows you to solve complex problems for
really any use case also I'm planning on
putting out a lot more content in the
near future for different AI agent
architectures and continuing to build
powerful agents with pantic AI and L
graph so if you appreciated this video
and you're looking forward to more
things AI AG pantic Ai and L graph I
would really appreciate a like and a
subscribe and with that I will see you
in the next video